>> Tucker: ABOUT A WEEK AGO, A
SCHOOL PRINCIPAL AND NEW JERSEY
SENT AN EMAIL APOLOGY FOR A
PHOTOGRAPH THAT APPEARED IN THE
SCHOOL’S YEARBOOK.
THE PICTURE WAS TAKEN IN
OCTOBER.
WHAT WAS THE PICTURE?
IT WASN’T OF THE VIRGINIA
GOVERNOR, THEY WEREN’T WEARING
CLAN ROBES, CARING AND AMERICAN
FLAG WITH A BLUE STRIPE ON IT.
THEY WERE THERE FOR THE DARE
PROGRAM, THE MOST WHOLESOME
SCENARIO YOU CAN IMAGINE BUT THE
IMAGE HORRIFIED THE PRINCIPLE OF
THE SCHOOL.
HE WROTE THAT THE PICTURE WAS
UNDERSTANDABLY APPALLING AND
THEN CONTINUED WITH SMOKE SPEAK
FITTING THE CORPORATE HR
DEPARTMENT "THE NEED FOR GROWTH
AS A PARENT.
I WISH WE HAD REALIZED ANY OF
THE NEGATIVE ASSOCIATIONS WITH
THE PICTURE.
WE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN.
I PERSONALLY CAN ONLY APOLOGIZE
THAT I DID NOT.
SOME PARENTS WERE CONFUSED BY
THIS.
ONE OF THEM, A FATHER RESPONDED
THIS WAY WRITING "AS A PARENT
AND AN AMERICAN, I FIND YOUR
LETTER TO NOT ONLY BE
CONDESCENDING BUT ALSO
EXPERIENCED, MISGUIDED, AND
IRONICALLY INTOLERANT OF ANYONE
HOLDING VIEWS WHICH CONFORMS TO
CAREFULLY CONSTRUCTED LANGUAGE
OF WOKENESS.
THAT PARENT JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
SO I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR TO
THE AUDIENCE, SOMETIMES YOU HAVE
GUESTS ON, YOU ARE NOT A
POLITICAL ACTIVIST, NOT A VERY
POLITICAL PERSON, YOU DON’T HAVE
SOME COMPLEX POLITICAL AGENDA,
JUST A PARENT WITH KIDS IN THE
SCHOOL, AND YOU WERE CONFUSED BY
WHAT THE PRINCIPAL SAID AND I’LL
LET YOU TAKE IT FROM THERE.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
I ACTUALLY WASN’T REALLY
CONFUSED.
I KNEW EXACTLY WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN, I FOLLOW THE NEWS AND I
SEE WHAT’S HAPPENING WITH
CANCELED CULTURE AND ANYONE WHO
SPEAKS OUT AND DARES TO VEER OFF
AND THE CONSTRUCTED SCRIPT THAT
BUSINESSES AND POLITICIANS ARE
MEANT TO CONVEY WHEN THEY’RE
SPEAKING ABOUT THESE THINGS, BUT
WHAT REALLY SEEMED APPALLING TO
ME ACTUALLY MUCH MORE SO THAN A
PHOTOGRAPH OF FOOTBALL PLAYERS
HOLDING AN AMERICAN FLAG, WHAT
WAS TRULY APPALLING WAS THE FACT
THAT IT SEEMS WAS REACTING
WITHOUT EVEN THINKING ABOUT
KIDS.
SO HE IS CALLING THE FLAG THAT
THESE BOYS ARE HOLDING, CALLING
THE FLAG RACIST SO ESSENTIALLY
SAYING THEY ARE OUT THERE WAVING
A RACIST FLAG AROUND WITHOUT ANY
REGARD TO WHAT THAT MIGHT MEAN
FOR THE BOYS IMAGES OVER THE
BOY’S FUTURE FUTURES NOW TO BE
BRANDED IN SUCH A WAY THAT
CLEARLY WASN’T THEIR INTENTION.
IN I WAS AT THAT FOOTBALL GAME
THAT DAY AND I REMEMBER WHEN
THEY WERE HONORING THE PROGRAM
AND IT CAME OUT AND SO THAT’S
WHERE IT CAME IN.
THERE SEEM TO BE LOTS OF SCHOOL
UNITY THAT NIGHT AND CLEARLY AT
THAT TIME, NO ONE HAD AN
OBJECTION TO HOLDING AN AMERICAN
FLAG HORUS AND BLUE LINE FLAG,
SO WHEN I SEE THAT LEVEL OF
HYPOCRISY, IT DID INSPIRE ME TO
WRITE A LETTER.
HAD NO INTENTION OF IT GOING ANY
FURTHER THAN THE SCHOOL BOARD
AND THE PRINCIPAL AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT, BUT WHEN I WAS
ASKED TO TALK ABOUT THAT, I FELT
IT WAS MY DUTY AS A FATHER AND
AS A CITIZEN TO ACTUALLY STAND
UP AND SAY WHAT I’M SAYING
SHOULDN’T BE CONTROVERSIAL, AND
IT SHOULDN’T BE POLARIZING.
AS POLARIZING AS THAT EMAIL THAT
WE ALL RECEIVED WAS.
I’M JUST TALKING ABOUT FREE
SPEECH AND TALKING ABOUT THE
IDEA THAT WE SHOULD NOT BE SO
QUICK TO JUDGE ONE ANOTHER BASED
ON WHAT THE CURRENT CULTURE IS
TELLING US IS SO.
>> Tucker: EVERY POINT YOU’VE
MADE IS ROOTED IN COMMON SENSE
AND DECENCY AND CONCERN FOR
OTHER PEOPLE AND I BET YOU 85%
OF AMERICANS WOULD AGREE WITH
EVERY WORD THAT JUST CAME OUT OF
YOUR MOUTH AND YET TAKING A REAL
RISK COMING ON THE SHOW, A RISK
YOUR LIVELIHOOD AND FAMILY WE
ARE NOT OVERSTATING THAT.
SO I JUST REALLY FERVENTLY HOPE
YOU ARE NOT PUNISHED FOR SAYING
WHAT MOST PEOPLE THINK IN A
GENTLE RATIONAL WAY.
I REALLY DO.
SO OUR THOUGHTS ARE WITH YOU
TONIGHT, THANK YOU FOR STANDING